ستثمرت منصات التواصل كثير في الذكاء
الاصطناعي للسنوات وعام 20 23 سيشهدوا
تغييرات كبيره في طريقه ادارتنا لحساباتنا
فورس وادي دراسات تحليليه اخرى تطبيقات
ذكاء الاصطناعي سيكون لها سيطره اكبر على
محتواك الخاص تلك التطبيقات يمكنها مراجعه
تاريخك لافتراضي على منصات التواصل
والحفاظ على اسلوبك اثناء كتابه محتوى
يشبهك قبل نشره ما يضمن بقائك متصلا مع
اصدقائك وجمهورك دون ان تكتب حرفا واحدا
بنفسه في مجال التسويق على السوشيال ميديا
مثلا يمكن ان يتولى الذكاء الاصطناعي
الحملات الاعلاميه الصور لنفسه يكتب
التعليقات يروج لها عبره حسابات الشركات
وفقا للجداول زمنيه محدده ويمكنها ايضا
الرد على اسئله العملاء
هاي سيري
ما اعتقالنا الى عام 2023 تستعد منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي لمجموعه جديده من
التغييرات على خوارزمياتها ولكن في
البدايه لابد ان نتحدث عن الذكاء
الاصطناعي
اندهشنا من الانجازات العبقريه للهندسه
وبرمجه الروبوتات التي تبدو شبيهه
بالانسان فقط
حتى تصبح هذه القدرات اذكى منها جميله
او حتى جبتيه كيف يساعد في كتابه التقرير
او حتى تسميه التوضيحيه لوسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
او الافتراضيه في النهايه بمعظم الاعمال
التفصيليه
سوف يكرهون هذا بالطبع انهم لا يرجعون اي
شيء من الروبوتات
[موسيقى]
ومع ذلك فان وسائل التواصل الاجتماعيه
المدعومه بالذكاء الاصطناعي ستاتي بوقت
اقرب مما كنا نعتقد فبحلول نهايه عام 2023
سيغيروا الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل جذري
استخدامنا للشبكات الاجتماعيه فتكون
متابعين لصباح العربيه ريتا سليمان واشنطن
على كل المزيد ينضم الينا من عمان رئيس
سنور خبير التقني سيدرايد اهلا بك يعني
كيف سيغير ذكاء الاصطناعي من شكل وواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هل نتوقع تقنيات
وخيارات جديده متطوره العمل المقبل
صباح الخير نعم نعم
التغيير تغيير الشامل تغيير الراس على عقد
تماما يعني لن تكون منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي على ما هي عليه الان الحقيقه
اكثر ما سوف يتاثر في مرحله الذكاء
الاصطناعي مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اللي
هي ثلاث شغلات هالشغله الاولى اللي هو
محتوى المكتوب انتهى تماما هذا سوف ينتهي
الى غير رجعه ملفات تعريف الارتباط والان
نتحدث عن تقنيات
نعم نعم
ملفات تعريف الارتباط الكوكيز التي يدور
حولها دائما شبهات في موضوع الخصوصيه ايضا
هذه سوف تنتهي بشكل كامل الانتقال الى
مرحله الفيديو مرحله المحتوى المعالج من
خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي بالفيديو هو الذي
سوف يكون مسيطره بالتواصل الاجتماعي
العادي تقليدي اللي احنا الان بنعيش فيه
من خلاله من جهاز الى جهاز التواصل لكن من
خلال الذكاء الاصطناعي سوف يكون من جهاز
الى دماغ بريه
او من برينسوديفايز اه حلو
لمرحله التخاطر من خلال برينتو برينكيشن
بعمليه
يعني هذا كلام خطير خليني بس انا ابلش معك
الصين طورت الذكاء الاصطناعي لتحديد درجه
ولاء الشخص للحزب الحاكم في الصين
فبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن سلاح جديد قادم
ربما قد يكون اخطر من الاسلحه التقليديه
التي نعرفها فهل يجب علينا ان نقلق في
عالم السوشل ميديا وتوظيف اذا كان الصناعي
معه
انا انا اقول كمستخدمين عرب في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط انا اقول نعم علينا ان نقلق
لان احنا للاسف احنا نستخدم هذه التقنيات
يعني مستهلكين لهذه التقنيات ولسنا همم
مبدعين او خالقين لهذه التقنيات لسنا
مصنعين لها فبالتالي نعم علينا ان نقلق
لانه ما وراء هذه التقنيات الان اكبر
بكثير مما كان على منصات التواصل يعني
بملفات تعريف الارتباط كانوا يلتقطوا
اهتماماتنا من خلال البحث من خلال كلمات
مفتاحيه معينه انتقل المساله الان بالذكاء
الاصطناعي الى مرحله
محاكاه الشعور بمعنى انه باطن الباطن الان
سوف يكون مكشوف مثل هذه التقنيات الان
يعني ومن هون حكيت انا ملفات تعريف
الارتباط الى حيث لا رجعه لانه الخصوصيه
انتهت بشكل كامل مع وجود منصات اييي
تخدمها الذكاء الاصطناعي في عمليه الذكري
الصناعي سيكون من الدماغ البشري الى
الذكاء الاصطناعي هل سنسلم بذلك لشريحه
ايلون ماسك هل ستكون الشريحه اكثر
استثمارا وتقبلا من الناس للزراها
والله شوفي انا دائما
بالتقنيات كل ما يتم نشر عبر الافلام
عبر الدراما
بعد سنوات يكون محقق على ارض الواقع وكل
ما يتم نشره من خلال الاشخاص المؤثرين
تحديدا في صناعه
ومنهم ماسك انا اعتقد نعم تم نشر هذه
الشريحه قبل سنه ونص تقريبا والان انا
اعتقد انها سوف تكون امرا واقعا لا مجال
ولا مسافه فيه بمعنى انه حتى جواز السفر
حيكون بالشريحه الدم بالشريحه الحساب
البنكي بالشريحه وبالتالي يتحول الانسان
الى
شبه روبوت بمعنى تتحكم به شريحه مربوطه
بالذكاء بس فقط سريعا هل سنذهب ابعد من
الفلتر اليوم هل سيكون لكل منا خلص افاتار
نهائي بشكل كامل وهل سنه نستطيع زياده عدد
متابعينا من خلال ذكاء الصناعي
القرين الذين تحدث عنه الان هو قريب مخفي
الان القرين الرقمي
نورتنا شكرا